[Music]
are you guys calling me no possum
anymore some of this I'm never watching
and be like I would like proud to have
little tits
but not that proud because I haven't
picked up we're talking about Shakira
actually okay so we're talking about
Shakira and if you're talking about
Shakira these days you're talking about
the Super Bowl and the halftime show
yeah no cheats good congratulations
dance no cheese well I wanted that no
way but I thought that I was gonna win
but they said go cheeks she cared that's
a good boy teeth yes she was shaking her
ass with Beyonce no I forgot
Latinas peanut night so that's tight it
was tight JLo they had a really great
performance it was really good it was
time yeah they both look so [ __ ] hot
thanks B feet yes
so she's 15 she's 46
both look very good Jimmy I was more of
a fan of secure it's just because I feel
like JLo is kind of lost her but it's
like gotten really small over the years
she got it it looks fake right now like
she got it like you you got it lifted
and tightened by me you could pair j.lo
booty to Celine cuz if you watch Selena
and you see J Lo's but it's like whole J
Lo's but like eight months ago in that
[ __ ] stripper movie mmm so she was
she was flaunting her skills from that
stripper movie in the halftime show with
this something about that ass makes a
man's heart really warm yeah oh the
heart in his pants
still got it oh okay yeah they were
skinny I don't make up I feel mostly
that JLo was moved around but I think
that Shakira still got it
so Chiquita was had who's that yeah
Shakira has a lot of any fluid and not
just that but she was using a lot of
like her culture into this performance
right looking hip things right and in
Dublin is from like the Arab yeah she's
like she's part Arabic guys yeah well
she's Lebanese and Colombian and so like
in the part of her hometown in Colombia
the the type of like shuffle dancing
type of moves
that's don't yeah so and I'm from
pornhub weird like lick and microphone
like that is like you know yeah so
here's some images I'm gonna play gold
and silver so you guys can see for
yourselves that's part right here yes
alright don't move your head don't move
your head
oh yes because I think Shakira's always
been better in my opinion
agreed better ask better dancer she's so
nothing I don't know about actress cuz I
never seen her she's really smart - she
speaks like five different languages
really yeah I mean she cares uh she she
came up as a musician where JLo was a
dancer on a living color and when I
think it Amol has a more diverse career
yes yeah but it she here is a great
musician and performer he's a great
artist jail is a great [ __ ]
businessman JLo has made way funnier
movies has secured ever acted as you can
okay so the reason why it was a crotch
highlights is because Twitter went off
and just a lot of a lot of women mainly
they were just saying this is absolutely
the worst the most vulgar halftime show
was always really high
older conservative women won't be
comfortable in your [ __ ] sexuality
you should flaunt it too why the women
always gotta pull women down damn it I
hate why it's cuz when they put that
[ __ ] on like their [ __ ] like has three
[ __ ] foals coming out I feel like
that's fine that's natural but if they
can embrace it and be like I [ __ ] up
threefold look gentlemen that's all I'm
saying it's jealousy it's [ __ ] so
there's another one says I was
embarrassed for my kids and ashamed of
Fox for televising it well your kids are
gonna like [ __ ] one day and just get
used to it like and plus of a thing are
they dumb because like it's Fox bro like
I grew up watching me with children on
Fox you don't saying I was like one of
the most sexual secrets we thought Fox
was the more like those games gear yeah
I agree
yeah he was so [ __ ] onto that show I
could my friend but I [ __ ] my
television box and to me growing up like
that was like oh [ __ ] there's nothing
about this that was the edgy [ __ ] until
South Park and I was like Simpsons
sucked America's so afraid of [ __ ]
sexuals yeah and it's not even that
sexual it's just it's just I don't see
it as being sexual I just see it as like
we got some but that's not bad that's my
nature
that's the [ __ ] you queit sexual
sexuality with bad because it's
expression sir it's romance it's passion
and have two leads the husbands and
wives not talking about what they want
with each other to the kids being even
more curious yeah they're getting it
some deeper [ __ ] was just more open it
wouldn't be that serious I like horse
[ __ ] okay I'm in the horse I wish
this didn't happen to me too right it's
good they were not a jackoff so they had
to go and [ __ ] the donkey in the
backyard exactly I know you're about to
do
hey Jenna [ __ ] the horse it's like hey
Oh [ __ ] cold on you hey Tim what does
the word say when it's not on the moon
neigh oh I thought I was gonna say no
thank you
that's a goal that was better that was
better no the God says magic anyway so
you guys remember last year who
performed maroon 5 and this fool took
off his shirt and is awful on T no shade
but then the same women are saying like
oh yay [ __ ] Adam Levine he's so sexy
you don't have to pin now there's JLo
and Shakira and they're just tearing
them down well the guys complain about
Adam Levine being all sexy on stage no
no one I complained I don't want to see
those nipples I don't want to see his
body that's almost as Peter Pan ass body
[Laughter]
exactly I thought like I'll never
complain about this show the guys was
like this is pretty sexually it was the
man that we're trying to appease - there
yeah yeah so the during the run yeah
yeah yeah wait things getting sick she
just ate the channel he's like quicker
is uh yeah it's just really terrible
terrible I'm gonna watch it so I could
take good notes and like write a letter
my husband agrees and he thinks it's
loose it wasn't bad it wasn't it wasn't
I felt it was so empowering it put Latin
people on the map more it's like there
it was all Latin performers and it was
done to Miami Puritan Midwest people's
yeah says he's a big fan of that silver
rapper guy that's why he's watching it
but otherwise he wouldn't I what I
thought was dope it was like two
powerhouse women running the entire
[ __ ] why'd it have to take two GL why
couldn't it have one
at one Wynn had done it and why were
they so sexualized I got this because
everyone's always say what am I trying
to tear each other down all the [ __ ]
time and now there's two women sharing
the stage and going [ __ ] yes no but Geo
who's trying to tear them down it's
women on Twitter [ __ ] I already had you
what I know I'm the last person that
should bring this up but there was beef
before us but with JLo and Shakira
really JLo posted on her Twitter header
my ass is way better than Japan she
posted a solo image of her in like
promoting the Superbowl halftime but
Shakira posted one with both of them but
but but but but but I'm pretty sure
JLo didn't put it herself it was
probably her team there's also this
interview where JLo is kind of catty
we're more like she's literally kind of
being like well oh because someone asked
a question like oh how amazing is it
that the both of you are sharing the
stage and all this stuff and then JLo
kind of does this to Shakira like you
answer it and answers it and so people
were I mean this is the Geo mid and a
half ago saying how cool it was that was
helping women oh wait that's why I said
I know I should not be it was nice to
let her twist in the wind and I didn't
kill herself so that you for the
destroyer but I mean there's also a
super cute clip that didn't get shown in
Super Bowl after their performance when
they like five and hug yeah they did
this the decide oh [ __ ] they're like I
was like that's kind of cool and Lizzie
I like that Shakira initiated it cuz I
saw that too so what ended up happening
is classier it's good listen I know it's
gonna be brought up that's why I'm
bringing it up so on Twitter it was
trending to how Shakira is like there
were people were trying to lift up
Shakira because of the fact that
JLo was pretty much saying like I'm I'm
too good to share the stage and so it
was kind of like bringing Shakira down
so then everyone on Twitter was like
Shakira's [ __ ] talented she deserves
to be on the Shakira's way more time the
phenomena yeah she's an actual phenomena
that
also a thing circulating around this so
yeah well it was nice to see Latin it
really was it was cool it like J but J
Balvin G velvet oven and then funny
Levin bad bunny yeah there you go
they're so [ __ ] in right now I have a
big fan of him no love that silver you
know you know it's silly to is like
everyone's making a big deal about it
that night but like literally like who
cares anymore yeah no one can of salmon
or in such a stupid uproar man and also
we don't even know if all of this was
even orchestrated it could have been to
sound like to just hype it up even
actually your thing is real it's a
though in counterbalance to my usual
shtick it's kind of weird how like Tina
Fey and and Amy Poehler have to host the
Golden Globes like why the two chicks
have to host the Super Bowl why can't it
just be one chick wasn't intended
Jackson one time yeah Jenny a prince is
only one chain but was it Jim Jackson
Justin Timberlake marki Beyonce on her
own was it she was yeah she was yeah so
that was two years ago maybe just don't
get like be actresses like JLo and like
just let Shakira do it
yeah hey isn't that nice table got heads
bro she does I know I'm just fun I know
what please cut that part out
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]